welcome everybody I'm Jeff Sachs
director of the Earth Institute this is
the world leaders forum and we couldn't
be more thrilled to have a president
john mahama of the Republic of Ghana
with us and a very esteemed delegation
of the permanent representative of Ghana
to the United Nations the the ambassador
of Ghana to the United States many
distinguished members of the cabinet
many distinguished members of the
president's office it's a joy to have
you here mr. president and you know you
have many many friends in in this place
today the room is packed and overflowing
and could have accommodated so many more
who wanted to join there are 29
Ghanaians students at Columbia
University we're very proud if some of
them are here could you raise your hand
yeah look at that how good is that put
them up one more time I want to see whoa
and I know that our students know how
proud we are mr. president to be working
with Ghana in many many ways we were
just discussing upstairs very briefly
our ongoing work together in Bonn sasso
Millennium village just outside of
coomassie and then in the north I in the
sada region a new millennium village
which president mahama led us to and was
the inspiration for for getting started
with the quite wonderful support of
differed a major telemedicine program
that is very exciting and that puts
Ghana in the lead of
new IT applications in medicine
important projects in accra that that
are underway and I also have to say I'm
very proud to have also been a teacher
of your wonderful finance minister who's
who's with us and he was a great student
and we're so proud of him and he is
exemplary of ghana's great dynamism
right now this is mr. president you have
been displaying great leadership for a
long time as Member of Parliament a
member of the cabinet in many capacities
as vice president of the republic and
then becoming president when President
Mills sadly passed away and then winning
election in your own right in late last
year and we're very very excited to see
the progress that Ghana's making with
your leadership the country's growing
rapidly it's discovering many new
resources which are always a challenge
we know double-edged managing them right
it leads to great great growth and great
potential Ghana has been one of the
fastest growing countries in the world
in recent years and we're very eager to
hear your thoughts about Ghana's
challenges and future you'll be speaking
today on the topic reflections on the
challenges and prospects of democratic
consolidation in Africa welcome thank
you
thank you very much professor Jeffrey
Sachs for those kind words and thanks
for being a friend of Ghana indeed it's
a pleasure and an honor to have been
invited to Columbia University to take
part in the world leaders forum and to
address this audience full of talented
young people many of whom I'm sure are
already on their way to becoming our
future world leaders it had been my
intention to speak to you today about
democracy in Africa I had wanted to
speak about how in recent times more and
more countries on the African continent
have turned to democracy and the rule of
law about the pivotal role that
democracy can play in a developing
nation especially where safety and
social welfare of all its citizens at
once and then just as house prepared
preparing to leave Ghana I received word
of the terrorist attack that took place
in Nairobi Kenya where a group of armed
men laid siege to the Westgate premier
shopping mall and massacred dozens of
people it has been confirmed in later
reports that one of those individuals
killed in the attack was ganyan poet and
statesman professor Kofi Awoonor during
my journey from Ghana to the United
States my thoughts have been centered on
professor who know his impactful life
and legacy of literature he has left for
us and for future generations
coincidentally the death of Professor
who knows det Supt emma trina fest
is also the date that the late dr. kwame
nkrumah ganas founding father was born
what links these two men besides this
fateful date is the fact that they were
both men of conscious consciousness and
conscience to a man of tremendous vision
far too often democracy in Africa is
defined simply by the absence of
dictatorship rather than by the presence
of the vision that few all set and the
willingness of individuals to take a
stand in defense of that vision
regardless of the consequences in 1957
when ghana became the first sub-saharan
nation in africa to gain its
independence it spearheaded a revolution
on the continent country after country
followed each one claiming is liberation
from colonial rule it was a revolution
that was led by the people by
visionaries men and women who believed
that the future they saw for their
country was possible it was a goal worth
fighting for it was a destination wet
much in towards a dream for which they
would sooner die than have deferred it
was a revolution that was led by poets
and professors by singers and lawyers
and deliberate the wealthy as well as a
working class anyone who dared to give
voice to that vision they were the
politicians of that era the leaders who
were destined to shape a new world and
the prize many of them paid was steep
Nelson Mandela was jailed as wazungu G
watching go valishia Inca and fella and
equal opoku T there were many who lost
days
and even years of their lives in prison
there were also many who paid the
ultimate price and who lost their lives
and tali Christopher okie boy was killed
as was patrice lumumba stephen biko
Silvano's Olympio and eduardo maudlin
taking untold numbers of others fled
into exile far too often the collective
battle for independence in africa is
mistaking for the struggle for freedom
but the independence of a nation does
not guarantee the freedom of its people
and this was a significant hurdle than
Africa needed to overcome as its many
countries moved into self-rule this
belief that the revolution was over that
with independence we had arrived at our
final destination we had met the
ultimate goal the dream had been fully
manifested into reality now we know
better decades of poverty war despots
and brain drain have taught us better
decades during which Africa seemed to
have lost its way and lost sight of that
vision decades which were just lost as I
said it had been my intention to discuss
democracy in Africa but on the heels of
what has been taking place in Mali in
Somalia and in Egypt and on the heels of
what I was just taking place in Kenya it
is important to first ask why is it that
this system is seen by some as a threat
I believe the answer exists in the
vision when I speak of the vision I
speak of social justice I speak of
equality I speak of religious and ethnic
tolerance I speak of access to education
to health care to housing and to
sanitary conditions I speak of respect
for the dignity of the human spirit
these are the ideals that come together
to form the vision and that vision is
what fuels democracy far too often when
Africa's resources are listed the most
important one is omitted Africa's
greatest resource is its people and we
cannot continue to overlook this basic
truth as more and more countries on the
continent strengthen their democracies
through the rule of law something both
Ghana in Kenya recently did with the
supreme court challenges to the results
of our respective elections the closer
we get to the vision and to the
existence of that world in which so many
have dead to believe in if past is truly
prologue then it is safe to say that the
law in the revolution is over now
there's been a resurgence of African
literature and music the poets are
writing of protest and the songs being
sand
of extinguishing the fire on the
mountain there's a renewed sense of hope
for Africa a number of the fastest
growing economies in the world are on
the continent countries that have been
ravaged by war famine genocide apartheid
or extreme poverty are now experiencing
a reversal of fortune the death trap and
triple digit inflation associated with
Africa of the early 80s and 90s have
disappeared and indeed many countries
such as Ghana Nigeria South Africa and
Namibia have attained single digit
inflation with prospects for further
decline in those rates in recent reports
the World Bank has noted that economic
growth in Africa for the first decade of
the 21st century has averaged 4.7
percent as against the 2.5% for the
global economy in 2012 a few years ago
Ghana my own country was among one of
the most economically challenged on the
continent in the last couple of years
Ghana has posted some of the highest GDP
growth rates in the world and still
remains one of the world's 15 fastest
growing economies at the present rate it
is expected that Africa is cumulative
gdp would rise from 1.5 trillion u.s.
dollars to three trillion u.s. dollars
by 2020 this means the potential for job
creation housing quality education
improved health care modern
transportation networks and the
opportunity for quality livelihoods is
limitless
today Africa is home to three of the
world's overall best performing stock
exchanges and Ghana Stock Exchange
received the highest rating from data
bank financial services as the best
performing stock market in terms of
return on investment Africa has taking
advantage of the benefits of information
technology to leapfrog its developmental
processes today's subscription and usage
of mobile phones in Africa has a past
subscription in Europe and America
combined and the industry employs over
five million people mobile phones in
Africa today are more than just a device
for making and receiving calls the
instruments that facilitate access to
agricultural support services
microfinance banking services and
healthcare amongst others the world we
live in today with its mobile phones
laptops and social media is dramatically
different from the world that existed in
the late 50s and 60s by the principles
for which we fight remain the same what
also remains the same as the hatred the
greed oppression and the presence of
individuals and groups who feel that
their way is the only way for these
individuals and groups the prospects of
peace and democracy and the minds their
plans for dictatorship empowered people
are difficult to oppress educated people
aware of their rights people whose only
hunger is for the ability to rise to
their highest potential will take a
stand
for justice and freedom but freedom is
not given freely indeed it is not given
at all it must be one it must be claimed
and the price of the ticket is steep as
a leader it is my firm belief that not
only do people in a nation in a world
matter indeed the matter the most the
policies that our governments promotes
must be for the betterment of our people
the legislation that we enact must be
for their protection the democracies
that we build must shelter the freedom
for which we are fighting and I knew
that despite the setbacks despite the
senseless violence this is a struggle
that will result in victory and so we
must hang on in a speech delivered at
midnight just minutes after gonna warn
her independence our first president dr.
kwame nkrumah quite prophetic ally said
the deliberation of Ghana is meaningless
unless it is linked up with a total
liberation of the African continent nine
years later dr. Nkrumah s government was
overthrown in a coup d'etat the years
following the coup were turbulent ones
for Ghana the government and regime
changes were numerous during those
turbulence yes professor Kofi Awoonor
like so many artisans of his day became
a political activist he would go on to
serve
his country as ambassador to Brazil and
to Cuba as an envoy to the United
Nations and as a chairman of the Council
of State but before any of that in 1976
he was sentenced to serve a 10 year 10
months in prison after being wrongfully
accused and convicted of allegedly
plotting a coup well professor una was
seven time in Asha for prison in accra
he wrote the following lines at times
the vision of victory becomes so blood
and them so much is a haze and certainty
but somehow in this dream flick has a
little light which keeps on the set a
veritable instrument around which hope
settles quietly staring now slumbering
now but hanging on just hanging on thank
you for your time
mr. president thank you for those very
very powerful and and moving words and
you remind us of our own
responsibilities absolutely and I know I
conveyed the sentiments of everybody
here to express our deep sorrow at
Ghana's loss of professor or will nor a
great man I was not even aware of it
until you said it unfortunately that's
why I didn't refer to it earlier and
just shocked to hear this as as we all
are we had one of our team escaped from
the roof of westgate yesterday and is
traumatized of course now in this
horrible and ongoing ongoing terrible
terrible crisis the president challenged
us about fighting for democracy and
liberty and values and reminded us of
any great men and women who have done so
we have students here who are joining
that challenge and I want to challenge
them to get up to the microphone now and
before I have to call you and please
when you do get up to the microphone
just line up and state your name and
this is a wonderful chance that you'll
remember for a long time to ask a great
leader a question please and speak loud
mr. president murabba we are so happy to
have you here at Columbia University I'm
a my name is Jessica Ames I'm from Texas
and I'm a masters of development
practice student here at Columbia
University and last summer I worked in
Ghana with the UN reach initiative to
discuss how to scale up nutrition in
Ghana and so my question for you today
is
first to congratulate ghana on its
achievement of the first millennium
development goal in undernutrition
Ghana's really making positive steps but
we know too that there's a lot more to
be done and I wanted to know your
comments on your vision for scaling up
nutrition to the most remote and
vulnerable populations especially in
forgotten about corners of the country
so thank you Oh should I take people
yeah maybe 11 13 time I think and thank
you very much and I'll be very brief
yeah thank you Ghana has made you know
quite a lot of progress with reducing
hunger and just LEDs year we received a
prize among 15 countries for having
achieved the Millennium goal goal of
reducing hunger and reducing
malnutrition in our country and we
continue to make efforts to even go
beyond the Millennium Development Goals
one of our flagship program for children
is the school feeding program where we
give the children in our country one
nutritious meal a day in public schools
and this program is extended to the
poorest communities we did a rescaling
to make sure that it went to the schools
that really need them needed them where
the issue of malnutrition was a problem
and so because of that program we are
having one more children coming to
school because they are guaranteed one
meal a day and two we make sure that
those meals and nutritious you know to
ensure that the children are getting the
vitamins that they need we're moving one
step up to see if we can provide
additional snacks that are fortified
with vitamins to prevent stunting and
all the associated problems with
malnutrition to ensure that children
being able to realize their full
potential while they're growing
wonderful please that's you all right
hello I'm
and Mahama welcome I'm Cassandra Mensa
ramp I'm actually from Ghana and I'm a
second year student at the School of
International and public affairs I'm
actually the president of our schools
pan-african network and as agony and I
wanted my friends in Ghana who couldn't
be here to have a chance to ask you a
question so I put a status on facebook
and said I I get the chance to be here
can you just sort of throw questions at
me and I got very like a wide array of
question ger so I think I'll try and sum
it up into one so obviously you have
there's gida which is quite a big issue
in Ghana right now we have the National
Health Insurance Scheme we have issues
or illegal mining so obviously a lot of
God is doing really well but there's
still a lot of issues internally of all
the different issues mentioned and not
mentioned what would you say is your
governments because priority right now
yeah ok you mentioned I mentioned
several things I don't know where to
start but certainly I just make a slight
mention of gina gina was an issue it's a
very important a governmental program to
provide young people coming out of
schools to prepare them for the world of
work unfortunately the management was
not carried out properly and so they've
been problems of corruption and
misappropriation in the program we
conducted an investigation and we're
taking the steps to correct what went
wrong any choice is doing well we need
to focus on sustainability every year we
have an appraisal program to look at how
sustainable and the NHIS and based on
that program we make adjustments to it
and so I'm sure that with government as
the strongest guarantee of the energized
program we will make progress we're
tackling the issue of illegal mining and
we had a lot of foreigners engaged in
illegal mining I don't want to mention
one nationality but we deported
we deported thousands of people from our
country because they were engaged in
illegal mining and so we're in the
process of restructuring the minerals
Commission and creating the systems that
will ensure that we don't destroy the
environment as a result of small-scale
mining it's actually supposed to be
small-scale mining supposed to be
regulated it's supposed to be supervised
but unfortunately it's taking a 10 that
is detrimental to the environment but
what is the one priority in a developing
country you can't talk of one priority
everything matters health matters
education martez you know infrastructure
martez ghana is a country climbing from
lower middle-income to middle income and
there's a huge need for everything we
need roads we need real we need port
expansion we need a bunch sanitation and
so if you ask me to talk about one
priority it's going to be very difficult
if you have said a number of crises then
I could have talked up various sectors
but suddenly I believe that education is
a priority we need to ensure that every
child of school going age is in school
we've managed to meet the MDGs we've
achieved gender priority as many girls
are going to school as boys are you know
we need to make sure that they remain in
school and we need to ensure that when
they come out of school they probably
get jobs and so if you ask me the
absolute priority maybe it'll be job
creation wonderful and go
perfect answer for our students in
engineering architecture urban planning
it's a teaching public health it's all
important every one of your fields and
an important contribution to be made
we're also very happy to hear about
cleaning up the the illegal mining
because we felt a lot of it outside of
kumasi and they were ripping up land and
threatening farmers it was really a very
very difficult difficult period please
hi my name is Stephanie I'm wan-koo I'm
from North Carolina but my family's from
Ghana I've visited several times I have
kind of a two-part question I'm a law
student and a super student just to say
my affiliation one lawyer will ask two
clauses but just one question oh well
what my questions has to deal with the
role of the diaspora in in today's Ghana
how can we encourage that the other part
is still the same question but the other
part of that was that I do know people
who get Ian's abroad who want to invest
in Ghana but they're things that hinder
them doing so so you spoke about
misappropriation before I know
personally people who have tried to
start businesses and have been things
have been stolen from them so how can we
address these things you know not only
at a government level but on every level
to make sure that you know business can
really thrive in Ghana
let me take the issue about the Diaspora
and say that we're beginning to
experience a reverse brain drain and
many Kenyans who had lived outside
before coming back home and I die
investing or bringing whatever I
expected they acquired while abroad to
come and work back in Ghana and so we're
seeing a lot of gandhian families you
know relocating in Ghana and working
meaningfully I dined the public sector
are in the private sector there's been
also a reduction on the number of
Ghanaians who are seeking to go abroad
to look for jobs because partly of the
growing economy ganas economy has been
one of the fastest growing and in 2011
it grew at fourteen percent and so many
opportunities are coming up that people
in the Diaspora can can take up but to
formalize things we have just recently
taking a decision to set up a dashboard
desk in the Ministry of Foreign Affairs
which true our embassies would give help
to Ghanaians in the Diaspora who are
looking to either come back home or not
come back home permanently but to see
how they can use their skills to assist
the process that is going on back home
we are fixing the system and putting in
the governance structures that will
create an environment that makes it
conducive for people to come back home
and work and it does take some work
public sector reform is not the easiest
of things to do but we're putting in the
systems that ensure that the public
service is more responsive you know two
people that were fighting against
corruption the fight of against
corruption is a universal one and we're
doing a bit to ensure that there's less
corruption in the system we're trying to
let the public service understand that
they exist you know to give service to
the people of the country and that they
don't exist to lord it over them and so
that change in orientation will come by
it will take some time and we're pushing
it as hard as we can in the presidency
just this morning I was discussing with
Prime Minister Tony Blair we had a
session to talk about putting a delivery
unit in the presidency that works to
ensure that policies are not just ruled
out by that they get implemented and so
I believe that that change would make on
a more pleasant and conducive
environment for a desperate to one or a
10 home and work and when you do that
can we borrow that in the u.s. also
wonderful gone is the place to be no
doubt about it I'm sure that a lot of
people will be heading heading there
very very soon please yeah hello mr.
president and I'm Caleb Solomon and I
mean the engineering school America and
I'm studying Chemical Engineering and
hopefully I'm looking for it to him
going back to Ghana and help with the
year you know to solve some problems so
my question is do we grow and sustain
our political or our our our our
democracy if our democracy is destroying
our educational system because during my
time in high school I did three years
and somebody put it for you so can eat
us a little bit on the three years and
four years and how other leaders really
interesting like other leaders really
interested in education or they just
playing around with education sister
just discussed earlier on that I've
really appreciated thank you goddess
democracy is mature and will survive its
face various tests you know over the
last several decades and it has endured
I mean since 1992 we held we will return
to democratic and constitutional rule
and since then we've held six elections
this year for the first time we had an
electoral dispute that went accord and
we had a Supreme Court of ghana's
sitting for nearly eight months I
dedication dedicates in the issue and
Organians where for the first time stuck
to their television sets because it was
the first case that was being televised
publicly and Guardians followed it
throughout and eventually the Supreme
Court gave a decision I mean they were
doomsayers who said I mean I was going
to result in chaos and violence but I
mean gonna jizz you know wrote the
moment and I believe that it shows that
our institutions are getting
strengthened and our democracy is secure
but I understand the issue are talking
about it's about as shs and the four
year and three years yeah in the wisdom
of a government it thought that the
three years was too short and sweet
extended it to four years does a
difference in opinion between two
governments the other government felt
that and I speak for my government I
can't speak for the four years I can
speak for the three years the senior
high school period in Ghana is the most
expensive part of our educational system
and to extend it an additional year puts
a very serious financial burden on the
parent what we felt was that rather than
extended let's increase investment to
ensure that children get a quality
education within the three years to be
able to make it into University and so
yes we differed from our colleagues our
colleagues felt that it was it enough
and that they should extend the time to
give the children more time to be able
to do it but I believe that if the
quality of the education is not good
especially in the rural areas where a
lot of teachers don't want to accept
postings they don't have laboratories
and all that if you even extended it for
seven years that child is still going to
go and feel and so I extended the money
you used to extend it invested in
providing laboratories in providing
learning aids in the rural areas in
making it attractive for teachers to go
in and if you improve the quality three
years it's official
for a child to be able to make it into
you investor into Polytechnic or if they
are not able to make it provide
alternatives and technical and
vocational education for them and so
that's that was our opinion and I
believe that that's the best system and
we're going to invest you improve
education in Ghana wonderful thank you
and one thing I'd like to ask all also
of our students and especially the
Ghanaians students one of the things
we're really interested in exploring is
how to use online education at all
levels in new ways and at the Earth
Institute we're putting a tremendous
amount of effort right now into putting
a lot of online free open access
information and a lot of video
conferencing with universities around
the world and we'd really love to
partner with Kinane universities and
we're also trying to promote high
schools to have contact internationally
and develop international curricula so
students here that would be interested
in working on that please do get
involved because it's going to be a
major major activity for us please no
sorry we're alternating mics and then
let your next yeah hello and welcome mr.
president I'm umer mohammed I'm from
Ghana Somali you honey mr. president my
question is that too that's GPS
positioning but my question is to the
first one is there what are the specific
there what is the specific program your
government has Dowell they're like
reduce corruption because we hear the
our government says I'm going to fight
corruption but what is the specific
thing that your government would do to
reduce corruption in Ghana that's my
number one question and that the second
question is I follow ganyan news and
have read recently about taxes so my
question is that what are the things
that your government are putting in
place to make sure that we don't
increase text to make sure that we don't
increase taxes that would hang the poor
thank you okay I said GPS positioning
because he mentioned that he comes from
yonni and I grew up in goomba Heaney and
that's a neighborhood that i joined noni
so I know exactly where he's talking
about yeah but talking about the fight
against corruption it is a difficult
fight but it needs perseverance and
determination to be able to root it out
and it doesn't take just the president
it takes everybody to be able to do it
what we need to do is to create an
environment that makes it difficult for
corruption to exist you can pass the
best loss but lost don't implement
themselves they need people to make sure
that those laws are implemented and
corruption is reduced over the years in
the previous administration the past
four laws they pass the whistleblowers
bill they pass the financial
administration regulations they pass the
internal audit agency act and several
other anti-corruption legislation we
have come and continued that process
currently were sending before Parliament
a public offices code of conduct bill to
guide how public offices deal with
issues of conflict of interest and
receiving gifts and so on and so forth
we also are strengthening the existing
anti-corruption agencies that is the
commission on human rights and
administrative justice were sending
legislation to Parliament to amend the
Constitution to allow the Commission on
Human Rights and administration of
justice to take up investigations into
issues of corruption without first
receiving a complaint the Constitution
says that they can only investigate an
issue if they receive a complaint and so
they I stopped if they found you know an
incident of corruption from
investigating it unless a member of the
public came and complained about that
incident and so we're going to review
the Constitution to that effect we have
the rights of to information bill that
has been pending before Parliament for a
long time but when you pass that and
allow people to exercise their right to
information to demand public information
we are amending the public procurement
bill to make it more effective and
transparent in terms of public
and there's a lot that is happening
about their attorney general to begin
prosecution of people who are found
culpable in the Auditor General's report
in the past we receive Auditor General's
report that impact people but no action
has been taken against them and so I've
given the Auditor General the line sense
to go ahead and begin to prosecute such
people we need to deter people from
involving in corruption and my
government is determined to carry carry
the fight against corruption to its
ultimate end please mr. president my
name is Angela a faux first of all
kwabba I'm a doctoral student in the
School of Social Work actually had a
two-fold question but the lawyer beat me
to one of them so my question is based
on health and the wh 0 projected that by
2030 diseases like heart disease and
diabetes and cancer basically
non-infectious diseases will be taken
over the content of Africa and so I
wanted to know what is your
administration's plans to counter that
to plant the seed in a way so that Ghana
will not be heavily impacted yeah so
that's my question okay yeah thank you
and I guess that's a very important
question we're seeing an increase in
incidence of what we call lifestyle
diseases as peoples incomes improve as
people have a better quality of life
we're beginning to see a rise in
diabetes in renal diseases in cardiac
diseases and so many of other side
diseases that were not common in Africa
previously we have been concentrating on
parasitical diseases like malaria and
all all of them and I guess that too
much attention has not yet been paid to
these other diseases but they are
becoming rampant it's mostly an urban
phenomenon but of course you can find
some of that in the rural setting as
peoples incomes get better and so I
guess that we need to begin to focus on
that too we were doing that by
creating specialized centers for cure so
in kalibo we set up the cardiothoracic
unit we set up the radiology unit we set
up the renal diseases unit and so many
of such units that deal with these
lifestyle diseases but I think that in
the most bad prevention is better than
cure and so it's an issue that will take
up to let people understand that you
know your lifestyle can let you acquire
disease that you wouldn't have gotten
you know normally you'll be happy to
know mr. president that when Ban ki-moon
asked asked me to help organize a global
knowledge Network and the post-2015
agenda and we established a task force
on unhealthy for all which features
heavily the non-communicable diseases we
have three co-chairs of that a leader
from India a leader from China and a
leader from Ghana Irene agyapong who is
the director of health of the greater
accra region so Ghana is very well
represented on this global Commission
and it's focusing exactly on these
questions about this transition of the
disease burden how to make sure that the
disease's the behavioral issues and the
disease's non-communicable diseases are
well addressed please nd we will have
time for two more two more questions I
believe I apologize to everybody but we
we will invite the President back
tomorrow and and the day after tomorrow
and the day after tomorrow but please
let's continue I'm the lucky one Thank
You professor sex Thank You president
mahama for taking time in your busy
schedule to attend the world leaders
forum me at Columbia my name is cosmo
sevindim from zimbabwe my question is on
on regional metals and they are bearing
on your local on your locality in n'gana
as well and there is the relic of like
the Islamic Christian interaction
through
Africa like this band which stretches
from Sudan through Central Africa ultram
Mali Nigeria and Ghana which which which
is represented by the northern parts of
the country being predominantly Muslim
and the southern part being
predominantly Christian who have seen
this playing out in the Secession of
South Sudan from Sudan and we have seen
it again in play in there all concept of
two are a gravels in the Malian crisis
last year were seeing it in play in
Nigeria in the form of Boko Haram the
terrorist organization right now they
have the state of emergency and they are
northern provinces I'll let you know
what your government is doing to
counteract this imminent threat and how
you're addressing the what the
imperative like disparities between the
prosperity of the south and the relative
poverty of the not yeah in the last part
of the question you hit the nail on the
head you talked about prosperity in the
south and poverty in the north it is
that imbalance that that is the trigger
for tensions not that the fact the fact
not the fact that people have different
religions I mean history has made gonna
a multi cultural melting pot of
different people of different religions
of different ethnicity living together
in peace and harmony it is how you
include all your people to have a stick
in the States and in the preserve ival
of the states that makes the difference
if you exclude anybody and you carry out
a politics of exclusion then you're
going to have the kind of you know
reversal that you've seen in some areas
where you have extreme poverty you must
reach out with social intervention
programs you might be centralized
government governance so that everybody
you know has a stake in Ghana we have
what we call the district assemblies
common fund that seats eight percent of
revenue gross revenue not debt revenue
gross revenue to 230 districts across
the country and so each district
receives its share
of the eight percent of government
revenue and you can use it the way it
pleases they have an assembly they can
decide you want to build schools they
can decide you want to build boreholes
they can decide they want to build
mosques or cinema TR test or whatever
they feel they want to build with it it
is their prerogative Africa must learn
to integrate and include its
multicultural you know a nationality and
probably if they say gonna is a model of
peace and democracy it is because we
have been better able to you know
include all our people I come from the
north which is the poor a part of the
country but I see the social programs
going on in the north professor Jeffrey
Sachs talked about sada Saddam in
Savannah has a retail development
authority and money is ceded to solder
to implement programs that would bridge
the disparity between the north and
south of our country and I believe that
if we were able to do that successfully
it doesn't matter that people are Muslim
or it doesn't matter that people are
Buddhist or Hindu or Christians or the
Ashanti or they are 20 or the other
gumbo what they all belong to one nation
please
mr. president John coat a second-year
electrical engineering student and down
under graduate school and also the post
culture of the African student
substitution during the run-up to the
twenty twelve elections there was a love
inflamed ethnic and religious violence
most people blamed it on the
overzealousness of politicians basically
the lack of oversight or monitoring and
but then just before the elections and
between december and july when the court
decided that you should win and congrats
by the way we sorta worked at the
National Peace Council did and the
National Peace Council is composed of we
know jeeves cans religious leaders what
do you think as a role how can we
incorporate we saw the work that it did
we saw the kind of oversight and
checking that they had on our operations
how can we give the achieves that Cain's
the religious leaders are more formal
place in our democracy and extending it
we are trying to grow indigenous and
sustainable democracies on the continent
it looks like the typical western style
is not working or African countries how
should we or what sort of guns work you
will be doing actually seeing how to
integrate social economic economic and
ethnic stratification making it come
together as a whole to ensure peace and
sustainable democracy is on the content
okay thank you that's a quite it will
take a lecture whole day to answer that
question but I am a believer in the fact
that democracy is not a one size fit all
I mean they're different democracies we
have the Westminster which is a British
style we have the American executive
presidency we
different kinds of democracies and as
democracy spreads are around the world
the concept is the same but in
implementation it must take recognition
of the cultural peculiarities of
everybody and so we believe that our
current democracy takes the recognition
of the peculiarities of Ghana and that's
why we have a Council of State the
Council of State is made of eminent
citizens mostly cheese religious leaders
people who have you know gun at a lot of
experience in governance and
statesmanship and all that and there are
an advisory body to the President and so
twice a year and meet with a Council of
State and the pig things you know that I
happening on the ground that probably I
otherwise soon here and I have a session
with them and they represent a report
every year to the president about what
their recommendations are and so that
for us is an adaptation we have a single
chamber a parliament and we have an
executive presidency but Los Alamos lost
our British we use English common law
and so I think that every country blends
democracy to suit you know its peculiar
circumstances but let me say that in the
twenty twelve election it was one of the
most peaceful there was hardly any
violence does if I remember those just
one recorded incident of violence in
kumasi the National Peace Council has
traditionally played it through and I
believe that that is part of the
absorber system the shock absorber
system that Ghana has the role that our
Chiefs and religious leaders and civil
society organizations play when they see
there's a threat of peace I mean they
just kick in automatically there's a
threat to peace sorry they just kick in
automatically and that's what happened
in advance of the twenty twelve election
they I mean mobilized and went on you
know
an advocacy for peaceful elections and
they do that anytime there are issues
that could create social tensions in the
country and in advance of the Supreme
Court verdict they did the same thing
and so what we've done is to
institutionalize the National Peace
Council it is now backed by law and so
it is a statutory organization that is
responsible for early warning systems to
see where there are areas of social or
political attention and to begin the
advocacy draw government's attention to
it and begin advocacy to ensure that
peace prevails and so I believe that is
all those systems at work together with
Ghanaians natural you know phobia for
bloodshed you know we can sustain
bloodshed I mean Guardians that I mean
if I've been in different countries and
I will not name those countries where I
mean somebody is killed or something by
the roadside and people just walk past
and don't even think that there's
anything happening I mean Ghana if
there's a dead body people are going to
surround it and conjecture what happened
what killed him or maybe I can't knock
them and they're going to stand there
under the police come and if I create a
body and so ganas Ghanaians have a
certain sensitivity you know for human
life and I think that that natural you
know sensitivity guarantees that we
don't descend into some of the violence
that we see in other places but I
wouldn't say that's the only reason
we've put in mechanisms and systems in
place that ensure that where there is
going to be some social or political
tension the right mechanisms kick in to
prevent it from happening ladies and
gentlemen sad to say we've come to the
end of an extraordinary hour with with
the president first
I want to first thank our wonderful our
wonderful students for all the energy
and insight you bring we have many
projects around Africa at the Earth
Institute I hope people will get
involved we the doors are wide open mr.
president you've really inspired us and
given us many many extremely thoughtful
and powerful ideas we are absolutely
grateful for that we count on you coming
back soon any time you're in the
neighborhood we're going to and and that
means coming for the UN or other events
we the door is always open here ladies
and gentlemen once again please join me
in thanking President Mahama